I was like Hey Alexa turn on Spotify and
she's like you're all gonna die I was
like what I was like turn on Spotify
she's like nothing like what'd you say
she's like nothing I so I was gonna ask
you Mike are you more scared of our
adversaries teaming up like trying on
Russia Saudi Arabia and Iran or are you
more fearful of the AI situation that's
every single day it's getting crazier
and crazier and these robots are warning
us what they're gonna do yeah I mean I
I'm more worried about Ai and how a
state not aligned with our own interests
and our allies interests can use it
right so I'm not worried that somehow uh
China and Russia are going to meld
together as as you know some best friend
for life and and you know they're always
going to kind of come and go based on
what their own personal you know or or
nation's best interests are